PLEASE WELCOME A VERY SPECIAL
GUEST -- PINOCCHIO.
WELCOME TO THE SHOW, PINOCCHIO.
(APPLAUSE)
>> Pinocchio: GREAT TO BE
HERE, LARRY.
AND BEFORE WE BEGIN -- BRUCE,
YOU'RE A HERO.
GOOD ON YOU.
THE PUPPET-TO-REAL BOY COMMUNITY
SUPPORTS YOU.
>> Larry: OH, GOOD.
SO YOU LIKED THE INTERVIEW.
BECAUSE I KNOW SOME GROUPS WERE
WORRIED THAT IT WAS GOING TO BE
SOME KIND OF MEDIA CIRCUS.
>> Pinocchio: I THOUGHT IT WAS
GREAT.
THEN AGAIN, BRUCE AND I ARE A
LOT ALIKE.
WE'VE BOTH BEEN FAMOUS FOR A
LONG TIME.
I WAS TRAPPED IN THE BELLY OF A
WHALE, HE WAS TRAPPED IN THE
CAST OF "KEEPING UP WITH THE
KARDASHIANS," AND WE BOTH GET
ADVICE FROM A WELL-DRESSED
MUSICAL FRIEND WHO SPEAKS IN
RHYME.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
HE HOSTED SATURDAY NIGHT LIVE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
>> Larry: AND YOU WENT THROUGH
A TRANSITION, AS WELL.
>> Pinocchio: THAT'S RIGHT,
LARRY.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO BE A REAL
BOY.
IN MY HEART, I KNEW I WASN'T A
PUPPET.
SO I TRANSITIONED.
I WAS LUCKY I HAD INSURANCE TO
COVER THE PROCESS.
BLUE CROSS --
>> Larry and Pinnochio: BLUE
FAIRY.
>> Larry: RIGHT.
NOW, LET'S MAKE IT CLEAR -- NOT
EVERY PUPPET WHO WANTS TO
TRANSITION HAS THAT OPTION.
DO MOST PUPPETS --
>> Pinocchio: WHOA, LARRY!
WE CAN SAY PUPPET, YOU CAN'T SAY
PUPPET.
>> Larry: OH, I'M SORRY.
THE P-WORD.
I DON'T WANT TO OFFEND.
>> Pinocchio: BUT YES, LARRY,
SOME HAVE TO LIVE A CONFUSED
AND UNFULFILLED LIFE.
SOME GROW BITTER AND ANGRY.
>> Larry: I KNOW BRUCE TALKED
ABOUT NOT FEELING LIKE HE'S IN
CONTROL OF HIS LIFE.
HAVE YOU FELT ANY OF THAT?
>> Pinocchio: BIG PROBLEM.
ESPECIALLY WITH THE MARIONETTES.
>> Larry: OH, THAT'S AWFUL.
>> Pinocchio: LISTEN, THAT'S
WHY I'M SAYING BRUCE JENNER IS A
HERO.
HE KNOWS HOW DIFFICULT THIS IS,
AND HE'S DOING IT PUBLICLY.
MY TRANSITION WASN'T EASY.
>> Larry: TELL US A LITTLE
ABOUT IT.
>> Pinocchio: HIGH SCHOOL WAS
A TOUGH TIME.
KIDS CAN BE CRUEL.
I MEAN, THEY WERE NICE TO ME,
BUT I SAW WHAT WENT DOWN IN WOOD
SHOP.
THOSE WERE MY FRIENDS, TOO.
>> Larry: THAT HAD TO BE
ROUGH.
>> Pinocchio: PLUS, THE HUMAN
BODY IS KINDA GROSS.
I MEAN, MEAT STINKS.
I HAD A NICE CEDAR SMELL BEFORE.
>> Larry: BUT THINGS ARE GOOD
NOW?
YOU'RE HAPPY YOU TRANSITIONED?
>> Pinocchio: SURE.
I MEAN, I WANTED TO BE A BOY AND
RUN AROUND AND DANCE FOREVER,
BUT HERE I AM A MIDDLE-AGED MAN
I'M ESTRANGED FROM GEPPETO.
HERE I AM I HIGH BLOOD PRESSURE
AND A PROSTATE THE SIZE OF A
SOFTBALL.
BUT WOULD I DO IT AGAIN?
OF COURSE, BECAUSE THIS IS WHO I
ALWAYS WAS.
SEE, AND YOU KNOW I'M TELLING
THE TRUTH.
>> Larry: ALL RIGHT.